es un ambiente de profunda devoción de
grandísimo fervor el que presenciamos
este miércoles aquí en el sitio del
aeropuerto de endolo en quinchasa en
esta inmensa Explanada de 850 mil metros
cuadrados centenares de miles de
personas están presentes aquí hombres
mujeres familias personas de todas las
edades fieles también de otros países
africanos de Angola de gabón de
república centroafricana que han hecho
el viaje hasta aquí para acompañar al
sumo pontífice en esta su primera misa
en la República democrática del Congo
hemos podido hablar con algunos de los
fieles aquí presentes nos han confiado
su profunda emoción de estar aquí y de
presenciar este momento tan importante
del viaje apostólico número 40 del Papa
Francisco el papa que se presenta hoy
como un Mensajero de la paz viene a
abogar por la reconciliación por el
perdón por la pacificación de toda la
sociedad convoleña para
con la violencia y construir un futuro
en paz Este es el corazón del mensaje
del Papa hoy en quinchasa Y seguramente
este mensaje será el hilo conductor a lo
largo de su periplo africano Este es el
quinto viaje del Papa Francisco a África